now we have some image from physical
reality we have an interface that is air
and glass what I see here is that there
is reflection and there is refraction so
in case not not everyone understands the
term reflection is least reflects c1 and
refraction is Prussian right if with my
horribly broken German thank god this
course is not injured and everyone would
cry but you guys and girls have it easy
because in Hungarian you would say
famous every dish and fainter dish so I
think reflection and refraction is much
better at least much more convenient
question which is stronger which effect
is stronger raise your hand if you think
that refraction that this is this effect
is stronger to use some use this is a
question above this example in general
in this example yes so I can see that
the refraction has a more pronounced
effect and reflection here okay because
we will deal with this in a second
and what we can do is we can actually
write up the vectors that we have been
talking about for a case like that this
is towards the direction of the light
source there is a surface normal it
looks like this so the normal it looks
upwards this is where it's reflected
this is where it's transmitted we don't
have a vector for that and we have the
different angles for this wonderful so
let's take a look at the simplified
version of Reynolds equation at a
simplified version of Reynolds equation
this one at least is called slinks
approximation we have no idea what this
what this is about this is a not so
complicated thing what this gives me is
the probability of reflection so R of
theta is the probability of reflection
so as I have seen the image I am
interested in what is the probability of
reflection and refraction because I
imagined that the probability of
refraction is higher in this case and I
would like to compute it in some way in
my computer program well let's take a
quick look at this R of theta is the
probability of reflection and this is
important to remember because during our
calculations I will forget this
approximately 15 times so may I ask your
name Lisa okay well if I ask you what is
RT time you will tell me that this is
the probability of reflection
probability of reflection yes and
exactly because I seriously I will I
will be forgetting it all the time R 0
is the probability of reflection on
normal incidence so this means
that light is coming from if it would be
coming from above what are the chances
that it gets reflected and r0 can be
given by this expression we'll be
talking about this and 1 and M 2 are
basically indices of refraction we will
have examples with that too but let's
quickly go through this and and see in
physics making any sense makes any sense
well for an air vacuum we have let's say
the index of refraction of air is 1 and
this N 1 is the medium that we go into
so for instance here glass and let's see
what happens there but before we do that
T is the probability of transmission
obviously if the light is not we forget
absorption for now if light is not
reflected then there is refraction it's
simple as that so if I add up these two
probabilities I get 1 so let's play with
it are at 0 degrees is R 0 why because
cosine of theta so the cosine of 0
degrees is 1 so on the right side I have
1 minus 1 so the second term is killed
by this zero therefore I will have more
0 and R at 0 degrees this is the theta
is that decrease the angle of the
incoming light zero decreases so it
means that it comes from upwards what is
it this is the probability of refraction
of normal incidence so this is basically
the very same thing so if it comes like
this what is the what is the probability
of it coming back bouncing off of the
glass what's up with 90 degrees well 90
degrees the cosine of theta is 0
therefore I will have both of these
terms very simple and this is going to
be 1 so the probability of reflection at
90 degrees is 1 because imagine that I'm
coming from above and this means that
is a very likely chance that I'm going
to get through so imagine a super
crowded bus in the morning and you just
cannot fit in there how would you like
to go in and if you if you don't care
about the health and the intactness of
the other people well you will just run
in there and you know hopefully they
will make some space I have the best
probability if I run towards them if I
would be running from the side it would
be very likely that they would just push
me back there's a high chance that I
would be reflected so I want refraction
I want to get on the bus okay so as I
raise this angle from normal incidence
the more probability there is for the
Ray to bounce back so this for now seems
to make some sense yes well this is
still reflection at 90 degrees about
just three dimensions of you have to
think in terms of limits so what is the
probability at 89 degrees it's going to
get reflected if you just raise that you
are going to approach the probability of
one so this is a bit public demand that
you can see that there is like a
continuous transition from here there's
high probability for refraction as I go
to worst ninety degrees there is more
probability for reflection and we
defined that at 90 degrees we say that
it is reflection because I am moving
along the boundary and not entering the
glass but it's a great
I was thinking about this too before 15
so let's say that index of refraction of
glass is 1.5 let's compute this thing
quickly it's 0.5 over 2.5 squared and I
do the very same substitution for the
rest of the equation but before I get
this what do I expect from the plot
that's the another important
mathematical principle do this all the
time before you compute the result state
what you would expect from the result
because this gives you a much higher
level of understand
well I'm interesting in R of theta
what does R of theta probability of
reflection excellent okay please our
nails it again so the probability of
reflection at 0 degrees I would say is
something very low right ok so I have
written this year that R of 0 is less
than 0.2 not because it's the
probability of I mean R 0 is the
probability of oh yes so the probability
of reflection is low I would say less
than 10% ok so if I come from upwards
refraction is likely I'm very likely to
get on the bus if I ran into the people
from the front ok what's up with for
instance 60 degrees what we know exactly
what happens at 60 degrees because how
many degrees do we have here what is the
incidence now it's 60 and we can see
that at 60 degrees there is a chance for
refraction and reflection and the
refraction chance is
higher exactly so what I would imagine
is that at 60 degrees there is a higher
chance of reflection there is then the
previous one I mean but refraction is
still stronger as you can see on the
image and we are going to compute this
and we are going to be left you're going
to let nature be our judge whether the
calculation is correct or not
so 60 degrees I quickly convert it to
radians that's more or less 1 and so R
of 1 is 0.2 this means 20% chance of
reflection 80% of refraction it seems to
be in line of what I see here but this
is just my expectation and what we have
been talking about 5 over 2 this means
90-degree angle I would expect it to be
1 so if I convert it to radians that
this is 1.7 so R of 1.7 I expected to be
let's put all of these together and
let's do what engineers do all the time
open Wolfram Alpha and try to plot this
so I imagine that R of 0 is less than
0.1 so getting on the bus easily well
are at 0 is less than 0.1 so far so good
R and 1 is less than 0.2 this is the 60
degrees both linear fraction well are at
1 is less than 0.2 so check mark and are
at around 1.7 is indeed round 1
so apparently physicists are small
people and physics makes sense so pretty
good but that is something fishy about
this so did this this is correct I mean
what we see here is in line with our
expectations but there's something
fishing about this plot raise your hand
if you know what it is
I'll give you a hint this plots our
theta which is this is the probability
of reflection okay what happens after I
don't know if I would just extrapolate
what would happen that's not 1.5 - what
would I measure I think it would be
something like the very least moments
it's going upwards but it would be at
least three I don't know about you but I
don't know problems about probabilities
that can be larger than one right so
this would give me some fishy results if
I would substitute something like that
so let's try to shed some more light on
what if I have a vacuum vacuum
interaction so below I don't have glass
alum work I have a vacuum
well the index of refraction of vacuum
is one so let's just substitute one here
so this is going to be zero and I'm
going to have the second term 1 minus
cosine of theta to the fifth why because
this is 0 and this is 1 minus 0 so I
will keep this term ok engineering mode
what do we expect from this plot I have
vacuum or air if you wish if you will
and vacuum again I start a ray of light
what will happen with probability of 1
reflection or refraction raise your hand
if you know
there should be no reflection exactly
why exactly
so the definition of vacuum is again
nothing there's nothing in there there's
nothing that could reflect this light
this ray of light back if there's vacuum
we expect rays of light to travel in
vacuum indefinitely
there's no way that it could be
reflected so since r0 is the probability
of G and this R sorry R theta what do I
think this should be if there's only
refraction then this R of theta will be
fantastic
okay well let's let's plot this this
looks like 1 minus cosine theta to the
fifths this is already fishy but that's
the Coulomb blah blah blah this is what
I've been talking about so I expect it
to be zero let's plot it and this looks
like this which is not constant zero by
any stretch so the question is you know
what went terribly wrong here and this
it's very easy the shriek approximation
is an approximation it's good for
interfaces which are vacuum or air and
something and not something something
okay so a and B it works well but it's
it's a quick approximation because this
is the original final equation and this
is much more expensive to compute and
this other one was much quicker but it's
it's a bit limited in use so let's give
it a crack so what would this say about
a vacuum back in interaction well I
would substitute N 1 and
equals one this is the index of
refraction of vacuum again the very same
thing back to see and once and then twos
are and go on I'm going to use a
trigonometric identity which says that
the square root of one minus the sine of
square something is at the side okay so
let's substitute these for the cosines
and you got it so what I see here is the
cosine of theta minus cosine theta so
what is this expression exactly how much
is it
please zero exactly and this is what I
was expecting
so apparently physicists again are smart
people